[Applause]
reign kept away many but did little to
diminish the spirit of the thousands
that came to protest
more than 19 000 people in the united
states have died in gun related violence
this year alone
and after the recent massacre of
elementary school children in uvalde
texas those here insist that enough is
enough we're not asking for a lot
washington dc's mayor summarizing the
feeling of all at the rally we're
demanding change and we're demanding
change now
[Music]
we need our fellow americans
a majority of americans who share our
values to let their senators know that
they need either need to make change now
or get out of our way
far too often we've had too many mass
shootings across the country and we're
not just going to sit around in our
houses and just let it happen we're
going to come out we're going to show
congress and everyone one of our elected
officials that we need them to do their
job
many traveling from out of state to
attend this rally tallulah came from
massachusetts to attend this rally
what do you want to see why did you come
i came here because
my school
they found bullets live bullets in the
bathroom the boys bathrooms so
it made me feel like i needed to be here
for that reason and plus that
this gun violence is becoming a huge
problem
[Music]
the rallies took place across the
country
[Music]
including buffalo still reeling from a
racially motivated attack in may that
took the lives of 10 black people at a
local market it has shredded our
our very existence people are scared to
go into stores our kids are scared to go
to school
it was a day on which hundreds of
thousands of americans came together
with one common message
mike hanna al jazeera washington